can i make one request uh
do you mind though if you sh i could be
shot in the head and they then discuss
this and the muller
another muller
was discussing and they said yeah yeah
okay
uh
you will grant you that
so then it's like my goal so i am being
executed
[Music]
i've been a print journalist in london
in my 20s writing for magazines
newspapers
style journalism used to go
nightclubbing
get paid to go to clubs and write about
it and then
somehow shifted into documentaries my
first documentary series the bbc was
about the taliban
and i became the kind of go-to guy after
9 11 for
islamic terrorist insurgents and
so i spent the next 20 years covering
the wars in afghanistan and iraq
and i think it was the first one of the
early documentaries ever made about the
taliban when they were in power i knew
very little i just knew rumors that
they'd banned
kite flying football
and it was like going entering the dark
side of the moon or landing on the dark
side of the movement you had to cross
from pakistan along the road
and kabul at that time looked like
hiroshima completely destroyed
and because filming was banned it made
my life very difficult
so i kept being thrown out of the
country
in jalalabad it was like a terrorist
training camp and i near my hotel where
psalm bin laden's house
was
about a mile down the road there were
lots of arab terrorist training and i
remember thinking this is
bound to come and bite us you know
on the nose and uh a year later 9 11
happened so in
2008 i'd made a documentary for channel
4 called meeting the taliban
i was only expecting about six or seven
taliban to show up
this compound is now full of taliban
one of the commanders taliban commanders
i interviewed actually warned me you
don't want to do this too often
he said before you came down i met them
in helmand
we took a vote on whether to kill you
kidnap you or let you do the interview
and he said
this time
the vote went your way but you'll never
know so
uh
and i i'm smiling but i'm slightly
embarrassed too because you know i had
two kids so i was warned um
what could happen so when channel 4 said
after that success of that film
uh
uh
why didn't you go to the
uh
tribal areas of pakistan just across the
border and it was considered the most
dangerous place in the world
and it was full of taliban training
camps al qaeda training camps
secret training camps why don't you go
there and be the first to film
those training camps and
when i look back that's not really a tv
proposal more of a suicide mission but i
said yes
when i went to pakistan in peshawar
in two in 2008
uh we arranged to meet these uh this
muller who picked me up in the side of a
car so when the muller arrived i knew
his name
and my fixture had already met him when
he appeared
and said hey you know salaam alaikum
walakum salaam and i get into his car
so i sat in the back of the car and
pretty much i'd already that was the
beginning of my kidnap
i actually thought oh this is good
things are going well
and we drove
into the uh what's called the tribal
areas of pakistan just on the border of
afghanistan and it was a no-go area for
foreign in fact it says got big signs
you know no foreigners be on this point
i remember thinking well that's
no florence unless you're sam bin laden
or other foreign al-qaeda fighters
suddenly as i'm driving up and we arrive
in this
marketplace in a area called
bajor and i'm looking around it was like
just full of taliban al-qaeda arabs
chechens all carrying guns and we stop
uh to buy some fruit juice
and i'm sitting in the back of the car
going oh my god this is just like
you know
open territory here it's there it's
their home territory it's their safe
haven
and then i was driven
up into the mountains
and
i
i mean i all the time i felt very tense
but i i'd always felt very tense because
when you go and meet
insurgents terrorists they're risking
their life to meet you they don't know
if you're part of a trap
so in fact the whole thing is incredibly
tense i used to have this routine of
battening down the hatches because you
don't want to make people nervous i'd
often met taliban
where you suddenly appear and they're
like you know with guns what's happening
and they're terrified for good reason
that they could be
ambushed by u.s special forces
so i used to sort of batten down the
hatches and just try and get incredibly
calm and i would have little routines of
thinking about friends and home
so you'd lock down the emotions uh so
when i then get to this remote area in
the mountains
uh
one of the taliban said to me uh
do you mind if we blindfold you and
as he says that i'm looking out over a
precipice and i was like
sure
he said you know
it's for your own security and then you
put the blindfold and then
i remember coming to the edge of this
clear fight scene
and that's that was the beginning when i
was thinking wow this this has been a
trap but you know what they brought me
up here and i slipped and i stumbled
uh
and then i heard
boots running down the hill and i heard
the
sound the clickety-clack of an ak-47
uh the bolt being pulled back and i
thought this is it i'm now going to die
here
and then i heard these voices saying are
you okay you fell down the hill
and they then i thought oh they said you
know you've lost your footing sorry and
they brought me into this safe house
where i was blindfolded
but at this point they were keeping up
the pretense that i was there to make a
documentary about their training camps
and also they promised that i would meet
the leader of this group uh siraj siraj
shakarni who's now one of the de facto
leaders in afghanistan
you understood that you've been
kidnapped
yeah what were your initial emotions i
think what the truth was i already knew
i was kidnapped
but you don't want to admit
the worst has happened when you don't
have to you don't want to confront that
news
and when there was no doubt was uh
uh the muller who i'd met on the side of
the street
he was in the room with us and he'd been
our point of contact
you know in the chain of trying to get
access to these taliban commanders he
was sitting in the room
suddenly this taliban commander comes in
with two guys with their black turbans
around their
face
and guns i'm lying in bed this is my
second third morning in in captivity and
i've been told don't worry you're just
in here and the muller was sitting there
who'd set up our meeting
suddenly this commander comes in and
starts gesticulating and shouting and i
i could understand the command is
gesticulating and the muller was
pleading
and then obviously when something went
wrong and suddenly these two guys put
hood over his head
pulled him outside of the room
of this tiny room and i could hear him
outside the door
and i could then hear this the the the
the flurry of blows of ak-47s hitting
his bodies and boots and the thwacks and
what sounded like
you know the barrel of the gun hitting
his teeth and
and the whole time as i'm listening to
this man being beaten
this commander then i realized became he
was the guy in control of our kidnap he
just looked at me and held my stare the
whole time
to see my reaction
and then i heard this body being dragged
off
into the distance
he said don't worry about it we kill and
arrest our guys all the time nothing to
worry about
and he said uh we're going to
investigate you uh so we'll stay here
for a few days and my fix wasn't there
at that point he traveled separately so
i'm in a a very tiny
it was like
you know
seven foot by six foot
it was a cell but it had a window they'd
bought it up and it was two day beds and
a little hole
you know the toilet
and i spent a day in there too until my
fix arrived
and then three days later the same
commander came back in and whilst
handing out gifts like your favorite
uncle arriving at crystal he said look
what i bought you
i quickly realized this commander might
be a sociopath because he could be very
charming and smiling and at the same
time
orders someone's death
uh
as he was showing me gifts like a new
show alchemy's big family-sized shampoo
from pakistan look i brought you uh
toffees from iran see how nice i am and
then you say see how nice and he had his
arm around me he then handed my fixer
my afghan fixer piece of paper
and that i could see my fixture
literally like the films
go white as he read this piece of paper
and the commander walked out and said
yeah answer those questions
and i said to my face you know what what
happened what what are you reading what
is it
and it was on headed no paper taliban
headed no paper
signed by the
emir uh you've been hereby charged with
working for foreign enemy governments
and you're now under arrest
and my fixment
we're dead
did you at any point had any thoughts of
escaping
yeah there was uh
so i i you know as a journalist in that
part of the world i knew a lot of cases
of kidnaps
in the past kidnapped people had been
beheaded
i'd seen the videos the al-qaeda videos
from iraq and that's always in
the back of your head cage in the
forefront
i also didn't want to my last regret on
life to be just as i'm about to be
beheaded thinking i could have
taken an opportunity to escape
but we knew escape would be uh
beyond risky because we we were you had
to get out of this house
compound wall compound you're
immediately in there full of uh uh
pashtun villagers who've never seen a
foreigner and then you've got
taliban training camps arabs
every night you could hear them
day and night test firing weapons and
the ricochet
you know i realized the place was full
of uh taliban al-qaeda and their
checkpoints so
we we never escaped never tried
but they they this house was a pashtun
family home was like a compound
and it was a grandmother living there
the grandfather
three or four sons men grown men and
their wives who i never saw
but i i
i became intimately uh
aware of of
through the sounds i could hear the
women outside in the courtyard
making bread in the morning and putting
on the firewood and making tea uh
and the taliban would come and go and at
the beginning the taliban had told this
family
it was a tribal well-respected tribal
family
and the owner the the main man of the
house they told him we were spies
unbelievers
so it was like again like the movies
where they would open up the door
and we just had a little bit of sunlight
coming through this gap in this window
so it was there was light in there until
the afternoon then it became twilight
and then we'd be sitting there in the
dark
but at the beginning they were just kind
of
put in a tray of food some bread and tea
or some rice and nan bread
and but slowly i developed a
relationship
uh predominantly with the owner of the
house this man who was about a strong
taciturn man
and obviously i'd read somewhere that
you know it's much harder to kill a
fellow human being if you see someone as
the label uh unbeliever spy or terrorist
much easier but to kill them
so i
i drew in all my experiences of living
and working in islamic middle east
countries of how to present yourself and
be polite
and i could sense it change but there
was one evening where
the taliban came in at night with a long
list of questions and it was the same
commander with his guide and
uh talk with shawls over their faces and
and they interrogated me i had a long
they had a long list of questions
and for some reason as i'm sitting there
the family from this house the father
that there's about eight of them all
came in these men sitting
in the
crammed into the room watching and then
up until this point this was about four
weeks into it they believed
the taliban that i was
either a spy or an unbeliever or
something not to be trusted and it came
to this point where of course i was
answering and you know everything i'm a
journalist i couldn't keep a secret save
my life
and suddenly in the middle of this
polite firm interrogation they asked the
names of my children
and i just suddenly felt i i can't give
you their names uh
and i just said i said i'm sorry i i
don't mean to be rude but i i
i really i just can't give the names of
my children this taliban come commander
said like no you've got to
it's not i'd be given this you've got to
tell us because they need those things
for proof of life
questions like that can be used in a
ransom negotiation it wasn't courage or
stupidity i just was unable to hand out
the names of these two innocent children
and i actually said look i i don't mean
to offend you and i wouldn't ask a
pashtun man the name of his wife i i
can't bring in
such innocent
light into this dark business
and the guy said well we'll have to
shoot you i've been ordered to shoot if
you don't answer any questions and then
a mask gunman puts a gun to my head
and
and i felt no i just like i'm really i
actually felt like i'm sorry
to let you down i can't give you the
names of my children
and they pulled the gun to my fixer's
head
i said well if you don't
uh
give us your children's names we're
going to shoot him um i i'm on stage at
this point because the family are
looking but i'm not aware of them
and and i thought they're going to kill
my fixes so i was like okay
it just and i and i was careful before
you never condemn them or get angry and
i i couldn't help myself this was the
only time i got emotional i said well my
oldest son is called luke
and my youngest son
is gabriel and tomorrow he's gonna next
day he's gonna turn four and wonder why
his father hasn't called
and i started crying
and to my
the great luck
of course gabriel is one of the holiest
names in islam the archangel gabriel
brought down the quran
to the prophet
uh muhammad
so
this had a transformative effect because
the these tribal elders and the family
who've been told all these men warriors
that i was a unbeliever
uh suddenly seeing this weak western
man
realizing that he's prepared to die
rather than give up the name of his
children and he's named one of them
after an islamic one of the holiest
names in islam at that point the family
everything changed and the taliban lost
face
it was a bit embarrassing for them
and from then on the family used to come
in bring me nice food
they actually offered me tribal
protection panna in in afghanistan which
which meant the taliban wouldn't be
allowed to kill me on the roof it's kind
of weird protection if you if you leave
the house you can get killed
what kept you going through all of that
time my children were both a source of
strength and my source of weakness so
you know
uh
so i hid two photographs from the
taliban and uh
of my sons i hid them into my boots and
at night i would take out the photo and
uh look at them
and
if you look to them
for one minute it gives you strength
if you look at it for longer than a
minute it breaks you because i realized
i'd let them down and uh
and it's strange you know i'm talking
about it now
and it's i think when you've had a a
very intense traumatic experience you
know it never fades from memory so the
minute you know i've just
you know you can immediately be back
there
so i remember writing a letter
uh dear sons i'm not your father you
don't know me
uh but i loved you more than anything in
life and i realized my son age seven
when he grew up to be 17 who didn't know
me he never had a father around to ask
questions
he'd be like [ __ ] you you know if you
loved me so much why did you go off
playing russian roulette with terrorists
so one thing i would do is feeling so
connected i would kneel by my bed
uh
as i would buy the bath in london when i
would give it a bath time for my two
boys so there were no babies so
at the time i knew there were being
baths in london i i would kneel down
close my eyes
and
because i was just stuck in this dark
self of every four months
within seconds i was there and i could
feel the contours of the skin beneath i
could hear them squealing with delight
so i would bathe them every day
so things like that to keep you going
so how did you escape
well it was it was like this
thinking back now i'm now
and in fact the worst point is where you
think you could be released
uh
because then you let down your guard and
and
and then you you're you're the worst
thing to happen to a hostage is you'll
get your hopes raised so there was at
one point
uh the taliban commander came in burst
into the room
with a sat phone saying
great news your tv company want to
negotiate i'm
like i know and i could think i'm going
to see my kids at last
and he said but thanks conrad
something's going on with negotiations
so i want you to phone them
phone your tv company
and say we're going to kill your fixer
if they don't pay this money and then he
looked to me conspiratorially like we're
all in this together he said look don't
worry we ain't really going to kill him
uh we just say that when we're
negotiating kind of
this is just a game
i make this telephone call
and i get the switchboard and i get this
hello channel 4 switchboard
and and somehow feeling that beautiful
estuary voice that london voice
it was like oh god i could almost feel
like i was back home and i said look i'm
really sorry
uh
a bit of an odd one this my name's sean
langan uh worked for channel four i've
been kidnapped i'm calling from the
triballers can you put me through to
current affairs head of news and
and then i hear this delay and then she
goes how do you spell sean langan and
i'm like
i am really shawn as you got kidnapped
and i'm like
i'm really sorry i don't mean to freak
out but i'm pretty sure he's going to
shoot my face if you don't pull me
through whatever you do
don't put me on hold
or voicemail just put me through to
someone she goes putting you straight
through and i get put through to
voicemail
and i'm down to like ten dollars and i
take it off and trying to explain to
taliban commander
that you've been put through to
voicemail
i because i could hear them i think so
at that point was in a bad state in
passion all like the only word i got was
voicemail
the commander who seconds early said
don't worry i'm really cool but he was
like what the [ __ ] his voicemail
he said and he just said
don't these foreigners get it
we killed people just to prove it and he
just at this point
pointed right at me he said call the
[ __ ] back and i just
see this he just goes
and i and i
i just think oh god and i go down there
and there's my fixer and i think he shot
him and he's just sprayed over the head
and he just
he just looks me he says someone wants
you [ __ ] dead something's wrong and
he leaves the compound
and then we're backing ourselves so that
was and then and then that was the
hardest time because then it looked like
uh
negotiations had failed someone had
messed up because then it's like all
hope was lost
and probably the one of the worst
periods was when the
uh
the family now
came in one they said would you like to
convert
and and and gave me a hot shower they
were but we were using a bucket of cold
water but they warmed up so i had a
hot shower and a new chihuahua comedian
they're asking me to convert and i was
convinced
because they said it's not good to die
without converting
these were my last rights i'd been given
a hot shower some food
and then in fact when the taliban came
back it looked like there was a guy
there whose job it was he had a big
knife and i said look
uh
i can't can i make one request uh
do you mind though if you sh i could be
shot in the head and they then discussed
this and the muller
another muller
was discussing and they said yeah yeah
okay
uh
you will grant you that so then it's
like oh my god so i am being executed
and without thinking about and then said
the earl of the house you know i'd
really go on and i said do you mind very
much can i ask him to be the guy who
shoots me
because my feeling was if you're going
to be shot it's that horrible moment of
fear like a mugging but actually if it's
someone you like and you spend time with
who's putting out your misery it's it's
just like
he was so touched that i pointed in my
executioner he cried
and then four days later the negotiation
starts again
and the taliban commander sits down and
it's like a court hearing and i have to
sit there and he's acting as the judge
and he
he opens up these official papers
and he reads out he says the the taliban
sure
uh
has found you innocent of all charges
and accepts you are a journalist and i'm
like
and so it was literally when you're
innocent of all charges and i went
good one
and then he said with great comedic time
you pause he let me enjoy my moment said
but they voted to kill you to send a
message to other journalists not to try
this again i'm like
and i literally
oh and i'm sitting there
and then he pauses
he says but don't worry the emir
strategy and i we vetoed the shura so
you're free to go and i was just
so within a
space of a minute i'd been told you're
innocent we're gonna kill you
don't worry
you can go and i'm just in
tatters
and then they read out my fixes
charlie said you've been the court sure
find you guilty of all the charges
uh but we're going to allow you to go
in fact we knew that meant he wasn't
going to be allowed to go
and uh
and the year before
an italian journalist and an afghan
fixer had been kidnapped and they let
the italian go and they killed
the afghan fixer they were friends of
ours the afghan
and i made a promise to my fixture that
i that
we would either both live or we would
both die
so they separated us
and we were brought out into this
courtyard now i hadn't seen sunlight for
three months
and i
see my skin for the first time and i'd
lost three stone in weight and i'm
thinking
so this point uh i leave
the mountains this house
get in a car
and then they asked me to put a burke on
so
i i had to change cars in the back of
the car i had to put a blue birken and
these little patent leather
ladies shoes i said you need to swing
the side of the road we're going
go and get another car
and as i'm looking at the filament
i see about 30 guys afghans and arabs
covered in dirt guns obviously coming
back from the front lines across the
border
and they're walking directly towards me
and i'm thinking what is the lifespan of
a white guy
dressed in a woman's
outfit i mean i'm dead twice over here
and they just ignored me and then the
taliban came in their car and said come
on in you get
and they drove me to peshawar
and then i'm kept in a little room in a
third place
and that's when they're negotiating with
my negotiators and they say we've got it
and they talk about this package we've
got the package
we're going to deliver
and that's you know i've made this vow
to my afghan fixer that
i'm not going to do what the italian
journalists did and leave them
so i say no i refuse to be released uh
and i said to the guy on the phone i
said no no you tell him i'm not going
you have to kill me.
and i and he's looking at me and all the
guards looming i'm like well
unless you release my fix i'm not doing
it and i turned away and i'm say to god
i've got about 10 seconds of this kind
of
faux courage that if if by
if if this doesn't work every single in
my body wants to be released to meet my
children
they look thinking steel's about to fall
through and then all right we'll release
the fixture as well
and we were released together and some
we've bonded out the back of a car i've
got hood taken off and this big fat
american guy
shakes my hand says welcome home sir and
i start crying
[Music]
you know one thing you should know about
espionage as well as bomb making
the first mistake is your last mistake
you're not going to live to make another
mistake and therefore you have to be
absolutely careful you know one wrong
word
you know and you are
a head shorter and six feet under